lire soir sur m6 était diffusé un
nouveau numéro d' enquête exclusive avec
notre ami bernard de la villardière est
une erreur dans cette phrase adressée
cette fois aux causes de l'obésité en
chine est vraiment bien alors c'était
vraiment très bien d'ailleurs il a
cartonné bernard bernard voilà mon
beernaert à cartonner avec sa hiérarchie
d'un million deux cent mille
téléspectateurs un des plus gros score
côté fait depuis longtemps et donc ce
reportage n'a pas plu à tout le monde
puisque il a été traité de gros sauts
fob par beaucoup de téléspectateurs sur
twitter non pensez quoi vous isabelle je
pense qu'il dénonce un vrai problème de
santé
regardez ça n'a pas plu à tout le monde
tiens je viens de la grossophobie à la
télévision mais j'en avais pas dans le
reportage à la 450 millions de personnes
chinoises qui sont en obésité
actuellement c'est un vrai souci un vrai
fléau national et c'est essentiellement
les adolescents qui sont alors aux deux
jeunes femmes qui furent ils ont changé
dans l'alimentation justement est assez
le fait que c'est un truc de fou
alaba cimentation rhône alpes alors on
vous a fait un petit résumé du reportage
on en parle juste après et juste après
on devra d'ailleurs deux personnes qui
seront avec nous et une personne qui a
été très choqué par le reportage d'hier
regarde assez bon hier soir m6 diffusait
un nouveau numéro d' enquête exclusive
consacré à l'obésité en chine
un phénomène relativement nouveau qui
inquiète les pouvoirs publics dans ce
reportage on a pu découvrir des camps de
redressement pour enfants en surpoids à
trois heures de sport avant le déjeuner
trois autres heures l'après-midi mais
aussi des programmes télé chinois
montrant du doigt le surpoids et dont le
but est de faire perdre un maximum de
kilos aux candidats quand tu faisais 150
kg il y a deux ans tu devais avoir
beaucoup de mal à bouger et les
pratiques autour de la surconsommation
de nourriture sont à la mode à l'image
de cette jeune femme très populaire en
chine dont le métier consiste à manger
un maximum de nourriture filmée et
diffusée en direct sur internet
mini à vaslui bol de riz à la viande 5
e/3 glace
et environ 2 litres de jus de papaye un
reportage qui a beaucoup fait parler sur
les réseaux sociaux de nombreux
téléspectateurs l'ont qualifié de gros
sauts fob le surpoids est la télévision
c'est un sujet qui fait parler depuis
longtemps en 2010 est aux pays-bas c'est
un jeu d'un goût pour le moins douteux
qui avaient scandalisé le pays
le principe consistait à devoir deviner
si la candidate était grosse ou enceinte
est relativement en france le surpoids à
la télé ne semble pas non plus être
quelque chose de facile à assumer qu'il
s'agisse de laurent ournac ou plus
récemment d'ayem nour les people sont
très soucieux de leur image et la
tendance est au régime
récemment c'est laurence boccolini qui
s'est affichée avec des kilos en moins
et qui a révélé avoir vu une
nutritionniste
alors selon vous la télévision est-elle
grosso fob la télé telles grosso fob
alors je vous montrais d'autres extraits
dans un instant de ce qui s'est passé
hier soir ça a plutôt très bien marché
et gaël nous a rejoint gaël vous avez 35
ans vous êtes influence us depuis une
dizaine d'années dans le domaine de la
mode grande taille
oui alors je vous ai vu tout à l'heure
en loge je trouve magnifique non mais
c'est vrai que j'adore supernova et
raison gérer les réseaux et à côté vous
il ya 6 ème siècle merci d'être avec
nous vous avez été élue miss ronde paris
2018 l'élection de miss ronde france qui
aura lieu le 16 mars prochain
déjà petite question eux je vous dis
j'ai la vérité aux jauges du tout voilà
moi je dis je c'est une question posée
pourquoi ya miss ronde et miss france
pourquoi ils sont pas toutes ensemble
non mais je dis la vérité
franchement c'est la bonne question à se
poser pourquoi est là c'est parce qu'on
s'entend bien tous les deux et non mais
franchement c'est vrai ils sont disons
qu on a pris l'habitude de mettre les
gens dans des cases
ce sens est d'avoir un idéal de beauté
et du coup là la miss traditionnelle et
l'idéal de beauté et à côté de ça il
faut d'autres miss qui exactement
mais moi je vous dis à toutes les
missions sont pas probants
mais si on les mélange et sont les
mélanger toutes les miss je ne pense pas
que que les rondes du coup gagnerez un
titre et alors ce concours là bas permet
de mettre au moins on est à coup sûr le
rhénan merckx le pire qui pire que le
mal le remède serait pire que le mal si
on les mélange et parce que du coup ça
serait toujours une mince il serait élu
les celles qui sont un peu plus un peu
plus enchères seraient seraient mises de
côté ça c'est pire et le meilleur
donc j'ai dit une connerie non merci pas
triste j'ai bien sûr ça voudrait
peut-être le coup d'essayer jeu gens si
beau si pas parce que jean paul gaultier
bien fait défiler des femmes de toutes
rondes ainsi m
oui mais les concours dis pas ça pour
être démago sur la tête de ma mère que
si m je la trouve bien plus belle que
beaucoup de miss france comité lui sur
la joue le dis franchement si c'est vrai
moi je pense que vous ne dites pas du
tout une connerie mais vous êtes un peu
trop en avance je pense que dans
quelques années alors à une unification
du concours des miss et vous l'aurez vu
venir parce que re a plus de différence
la physique comme ça toutes les miss
concourront paris quoi qu'est ce qu'un
haut niveau les chefs de bourg n'est pas
mal la dérange me seront alors les
chéris juste on va revenir au débat est
ce que vous trouvez que la télé est
grosso fort oui pour vous pour vous oui
oui en fait nommer les choqués par le
reportage d'hier moi j'ai été choqué par
le reportage dans la mesure où on peut
toujours être dans le cliché des gros
qui sont gros parce qu'ils mangent et on
ne va pas chercher à les raisons les
jambes à l'angle du coup c'est ça le
problème avec ce type de reportage ça on
ne donne pas l'occasion aux gros de
s'exprimer comme ils peuvent s'exprimer
il avait surtout comment on les
culpabilise presque vrai on dit bon ben
c'est parce qu'ils bouffent alors que
deux enfants à l'école qui mangent à un
même cantine et tout le bordel y en a un
qui garde tout qui devient comme ça
filouterie et sec comme un coup de
trique rayonne permet nous c'est dans la
tête si cela va peut-être c'est vrai que
c'est dans la tête
disons que l'obésité est atteint une
conséquence de différents problèmes
qu'on va voir
et pas que de la fainéantise et l'alarmé
tu es sage a beaucoup couchepin se fait
taxer beaucoup de 6,6 psychisme acquis
ces raisons médicales en janvier qu'un
rêve d'hier on a fait la rencontre d'un
père de famille qui est prêt à tout pour
que son fils perdre du poids il a 29
kilos de trop regarde moi je fais 100 kg
je ne veux pas que mon fils prenne le
même chemin que moi je suis prêt à
dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour lui
attention à 15 ans il mesure 1 m 72
actuellement il fait 93 kg son poids
idéal est autour de 64,5 qui l'auront
qui a fait environ 29 kilos de trop
critiques au congrès où se tient dans
ses 29 kg il y à 13 18 kilos de pure
grèce où s'en va donc se concentrer sur
le cardio des exercices qui font
travailler le coeur pour brûler un
maximum de calories et faire fondre les
graisses
allez bon courage mon garçon alors oui
costil
oui la télévision est léger bien mais
oui elle et gossau folle parce qu'elle
n'aime pas les différences et elle
reflète la société
deuxième point j'avais créé lorsque
j'étais au csa une charte de lutte
contre l'obésité on ne le sait pas mais
il ya des programmes et quand même fait
des choses il y en a qui font rien au
csa moi j'ai fait des choses avec les
trois barques ou vous adonner aux
artères une piscine
non mais j'étais une charte de lutte
contre l'obésité elle a dix ans et où on
oblige les programmes enfin c'est vous
plutôt volontaire à faire des programmes
pour lutter contre l'obésité et c'est
important de savoir quelles étaient les
minutes pour ça alors on parle de cette
la télé et elle grosso fox ce week end
il ya eu un truc assez grave voix qui
s'est passé sur les réseaux sociaux qui
m'a beaucoup choqué c'est concernant
luan elle était vendredi soir sur la
scène des 34e victoire de la musique
moi je suis du tchador loi elle s'est
retrouvée donc la cible de moqueries sur
twitter parce qu'elle aurait pris du
poids regardez regardez j'ai pris 28 kg
avec comme j'aime donc ils n'ont pas
pris l'extrait cette bande normal mais
voilà et donc il ya eu des heurts plein
des comme ça lorsqu'il est terrible elle
a encore tout à fait anormal aussi grave
non mais non mais c'est surtout van est
sûre ça c'est oui mais parce que c'est
la simplicité
je pense qu'on est dans une société où
il est très aisé de se moquer d'une
personne ronde parce que justement c'est
l'image que véhiculent les médias de par
les représentations c'est que dans un
film un gros il peut être juste gros il
peut être d'être rigolo et pas forcément
amuser la galerie a des répercussions
société et donc il est très simple de se
permettre de donner son avis sur un gros
tas prittas prix du point oh tu devrais
manger ça alors qu'une autre personne
mais jamais on va être au menu pour lui
parlerai pas de ça alors on l'a vu en
télé il ya laurent ournac qui a perdu
beaucoup de poids et à laurence
boccolini aussi patrice franchement
teinte et un animateur et un des
animateurs qui a le plus compté pour toi
ce que tu as senti qu'il y avait une
espèce de voile a eu de discriminations
contre les personnes qui avait du poids
en télé vraiment faux pas
personnellement autour de moi mais c'est
vrai que ça existe vrai c'est ça qui est
chouette si tu prends quelqu'un qui a
pris qui est un peu ronan il faudrait
que tu perdes du foyer qui perdent deux
fois qu'on a dit ça c'est nous ce qui
est des conquois a prêté on se dit moi
j'ai renoncé à un moment je vous disais
c'est pas bien il faut que je vois moi
je suis à 100 kg tour ont fait 100 kg
tombe un peu et je mange rien un proche
comme un moineau j'ai fait une cure
chinoise ouais et je peux te dire le
manger à ma faim pendant une semaine
j'ai perdu 12 kilos en une semaine en
mangeant à ma faim il était presque t
bonds énormes enjeux de la merde et des
poisons
c'est à dire pendant ces sept jours là
le mec qui pratique la médecine chinoise
j'ai dit c'est quoi c'est fort boyard
ton truc qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
m'a dit tu vas faire un truc que tu aies
jamais fait rien 1h dieu ça me va bien
ça et je ne mange que des animaux qui ne
sont pas des structures et et du couteau
organise tout seul fait le travail c'est
absolument étonnant les chinois ils ont
3 millions d' avance sur nous j'ai
trouvé le week-end très violent au
niveau justement de cette eau
grossophobie à la télévision entre les
reproches inacceptable injuste et en
double ou à ton contrôle one
et puis même l' enquête exclusive parce
que quand vous le regardez de bout en
bout qu'est ce que ça vous dit à la fin
je suis désolé qu'est ce que ça vous dit
à la fin être gros c'est mal on fait
tout pour mais gai mais c'est ça la
représentation qu'on a à la fin de
l'émission c'est ça on culpabilise
d'être gros et ça ça va lui sourire
j'ai demandé comment vont évoluer là
pour moi raciste au bal des faux culs
c'est à dire que j'entends que c'est pas
bien
la grossophobie ah oui c'est vrai c'est
pas bien sauf que je pense que moi moi
j'étais très rondes quand j'étais ado et
j'ai fait un gros gros régime pour
perdre beaucoup de poids parce que je
pense sincèrement que je n'aurais pas
fait la star academy si j'avais eu dans
lequel le plus
je ne serais pas là où je suis si
j'avais 20 kg de plus c'est parce que
non je ne pense pas parce que je pense
que dans l'inconscient des gens c'est
comme dans la publicité
c'est comme dans tout il faut être
membre c'est malheureux pour le
regretter c'est horrible c'est comme ça
c'est une évidence l'intention de leurs
associés tous en revanche moi j'ai créé
un blog il ya dix ans qui est suivi par
des milliers de femmes parce que il n'y
avait pas de représentation de femmes
qui me ressemblent à autant dans les
médias donc j'écris à mon média
aujourd'hui j'ai créé ma marque de
vêtements qui cartonne les communautés
qui me suit et qui milite derrière moi
et pas par changer les choses mais pour
l'heure grâce aux fouilles méchant
comment mais c'est aussi un an mais il
ya dix ans au moment de la star academy
à 10 15 ans on n'aurait pas pu avoir une
femme ronde comme moi dans une émission
comme un label rouge ou alors je vous
dirais alors il ya magalie vaé calme
avec un peu ronde qui avait gagné la
ville de niamey c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient pas nombreux
le ballon reportage d'hier il y avait
une jeune femme qui en chine a créé une
agence de mannequins pour rondes et qui
vend dans le monde entier en revanche
n'a pas besoin d'être très rondes pour
être moqué regardez khamis air qui avait
à bord un peu de cellulite et elle a été
victime ces messieurs ont eu d'abord la
sécurité ouvrent ou os mais moi depuis
que depuis que je suis ici ça fait un an
et demi que je me fais insulter tous les
jours sur twitter de grosses c'est la
méconnaissance des corps en fait je veux
dire que les corneilles ou non j'ai déjà
bien un problème il ya un mauvais usage
du terme groupe ont dit gros pour dire
plein plein de choses comme ça même si
on parle de la santé c'est un problème
jusqu'à de morphologie légaux c'est bien
connu et les grâces de botticelli elles
sont bien bien ronde à 0 c'est une
question de canons de beauté
il ya des groupes qui sont très très
joli mais je suis le premier à le dire
mais sauf que les médecins on peut pas
les taxer grossophobie les médecins sont
les premiers à vous dire quand vous avez
pris
et badaboum séculaire il ya plein de
problèmes sont creusé la tombe et
freedom et n ya pas de nulle part c'est
quand même une stigmatisation qui est
fait
bien évidemment on ne va pas le nier
l'obésité peut créer des complications
qui peut être voilà des des risques
mortels sans ne le niera pas maintenant
le parlons du métro je vais voir le
médecin pour mon mal de gorge pourquoi
il me parle de mon poids baisse et sa
chérie on va on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs la télé telles oui oui à
60 3%
non y'a pas 37% merci à vous d'avoir
avec nous et les deux premiers